bonjour nadège les députés se penchent
donc à nouveau sur la loi vient et comme
on s'y attendait les députés ont décidé
de rétablir la disposition centrale de
ce texte ce que refusait lé sénateur
le désaccord entre le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale un porte sur
l'obligation pour les plateformes en
ligne de retirer sous 24 heures tout
contenu haineux après un signalement
dans le cas échéant elle encourt une
amende de qui peut aller jusqu'à 250
mille euros voire de 20 millions d'euros
en cas de récidive sont visés notamment
les incitations à la haine à la violence
ainsi que les injures à caractère
raciste et religieuse inscrite dans le
texte validé en première lecture par
l'assemblée nationale à la disposition
avait été annulée par le sénat qui a mis
en cause une atteinte à la liberté
d'expression et selon toute
vraisemblance ans ce texte de loi
devrait être adoptée dans les jours qui
viennent puisque l'assemblée nationale
bien devrait garder son opinion à ce
sujet n'avait jamais razak depuis
l'assemblée nationale